[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up roof
good day walter hello martin how are you
doing
i'm still doing the same as i did last
time oh and that was good
that was good let's open with a word of
prayer
our heavenly father thank you so much
for bringing us again
together to discuss important subjects
god we need you in our lives and please
bless us
and help us with the holy spirit in
jesus name amen
amen now martin we've titled this one
final persecution
and according to the eschatology
as we see it things will have to start
moving in a particular direction and
they will have to hone
in on those that keep the commandments
of god and have the faith of jesus
yes because that's what scripture says
yes the devil was
wrath with the woman the church
and went to make war and then it
mentions a specific category
those who keep the commandments and have
the faith
of jesus later on in revelation
it defines them as them having the
commandments of
god and the spirit of prophecy
yes so how will this come about
now there have been a number of
presentations that have been going
around which have summarized these
things
and we just want to look at some
different aspects
just to get a clearer picture of how
this will come about
yes or how it will conceivably
come about shall we jump right into it
as usual
here's a statement from fundamentals of
christian education which says
when we reach the standard that the lord
would have us reach worldlings will
regard
seventh-day adventists as odd
singular straight-laced extremists
we are made a spectacle unto the world
and to angels
and to men now martin when you are made
a spectacle
unto the world that means there must be
certain prominence yes otherwise you
wouldn't be a spectacle unto the world
right
correct the world acts as a spectator
when it comes to certain sports events
so what will make these people prominent
and when they do become prominent the
world will think of them
as singular straight-laced extremists
and that's a word that we've been
hearing quite
a lot extremists in the
news current currently as another
statement from testimonies for the
church volume
5 our people have been regarded as
too insignificant to be worthy of notice
but a change will come the christian
world
is now making movements which will
necessarily bring
commandment keeping people into
prominence
so even the christian world will somehow
put the spotlight on seventh day
adventists
now i certainly hope that this series
that we are doing and these talks that
we are having aren't just for seventh
day adventists that would be most
disconcerting yeah true
i would like it to be a spectacle
for the entire world yes everybody
must be involved in this and i would
like them
to really understand because as we said
before
we are not seventh day adventist because
that sounded like a nice thing to do
as we said before uh once you consider
all the options
there must be very compelling reasons
why you would make that choice
correct or else you maybe need your head
read right
yes okay so
what is going to change and how
is it going to change that's the topic
that we're going to discuss
here's another interesting statement it
says i
saw the nominal church and nominal
adventists now those were people
nominal adventists would be not
seventh-day adventists
necessarily but people who believe in
the second coming of christ
have some notion that christ will come
at some stage
but there's no urgency right
that they like judas would betray us to
the catholics
to obtain their influence to come
against the truth
now what influence do the catholics
have to come against the truth
they must be somehow connected to
government right
in order to exercise that influence
correct but we've discussed that
so much there's no doubt about that
the saints then will be an obscure
people little known to the catholics
but the churches and the nominal
adventists who know
our faith and customs for they hated us
on account of the sabbath for they could
not refute it
will betray the saints and report them
to the catholics as those who disregard
the institutions of the people
that is that they keep the sabbath and
disregard the sunday
now some people will say they don't
fully understand why
why is this such an issue but we've
spoken about the sabbath
many many times who instituted the
sabbath god
god instituted it right in eden
and he says his law does not change and
jesus said i've not come to change the
law
nothing will change and he's even lord
of the sabbath so he'll tell you how it
should be kept
yes all right
now adventists will become prominent
why because adventists have this
this theology that they
should be a separate people
now separateness in this world today
is not a very well accepted term
inclusiveness is what we need in the
world today
solidarity isn't that what you are
saying
so to be separate is something totally
different
now the churches
that were all separate before have
joined up in the ecumenical movement
did you know martin that the the
catholic church is not really part of
the economical movement
why not because they
are the mother church the economical
movement
is for the separated church so there is
a body that deals with the separated
churches
and works closely with the economical
movement
but if they were part of the economical
movement that would be
like saying that they are at fault too
so there are two bodies and the
economical movement
has been created to bring the churches
back
into alignment with rome okay
so that's why she says i will not suffer
loss of children
so now the seventh-day adventist church
is not officially part of the economical
movement
that does not mean that elements within
the church
yes are not participating in the
economical
endeavors but officially
they are not part of the economical
movement
now people don't understand that because
they
see so many connections between
church leaders and the roman catholic
church
and also with the other church bodies
and they're wondering well aren't they
then part of the economical movement
you know martin the official position
is what counts not what individuals
do so as long as the individual
are associating or even partaking should
it be the case
that does not make the official position
wrong correct so if people want to
understand that here is a
web page and this is the official
webpage
of the church www.adventist.org
and there's an article at this webpage
on the ecommerical movement
and it is carefully written it is
diplomatically written but you can
clearly see
that it states that there are certain
issues
which do not conform with the ideology
of seventh-day adventism
so the official position is we are not
part of it
but that doesn't mean that we won't talk
to them
correct sorry i just want to also
include the
you mentioned the individuals and that
also includes institutions
or anybody inside of the
main church there is no ecclesiastical
decision
that this church as a body should be
part
of the economical movement
and that is what you obey what you base
your stand on
this is the official position
irrespective of what anybody does
right so having gotten that off our
chest
what is the official position of
the church with regard to roman
catholicism
now it's also very well worded this
document again it is the official
web page adventist.org and
seventh-day adventists regard all men
and women as
equal in the sight of god we reject
bigotry against any person
regardless of race nationality or
religious creed
and these are all things
that are right and that are good because
everybody is a free agent and should be
able to make their
moral choices according to their
conscience right
but here the question is what is our
position with regard to roman
catholicism
and although they they are not very
direct in this
document they still clearly say
that you cannot disregard the history of
the roman catholic
church when it comes to
the reasons why the world regards them
as they
do and between
the lines you can read that there is a
distinct separation when it comes to
ideology
yes so the official position as
we are not one with rome
that's the official position it's the
same as it
when they started and exactly the same
when people
decide they want to have a closer
relationship with rome
that's not according to the official
position and there is no ecclesiastical
decision where the church as a body has
decided
to give up its doctrine that rome
is the antichrist correct correct yep
so we are living in a world
where there are different people with
different opinions
also within the church and the gospel
net
catches all kinds of fish and you cannot
look at the fish
to say that the whole body is apostate
because there are certain fish that are
not in harmony with the other fish
so we're looking at official positions
here is an article also in a
in a very prominent magazine in
adventism
ministry magazine and they asked the
question are adventist
fundamentalists
and the answer as they write also very
well written these are all
carefully constructed documents
states quite clearly when it comes to
the official definition
of what a fundamentalist is someone who
believes what the bible says then
yes we are fundamentalists when it comes
to the position
of what the world thinks a
fundamentalist is these days
then the answer is no we're not
terrorists and we're not
trouble makers we just believe the bible
right correct
so those are the official positions and
that is the status quo what anyone else
says
is not an official position
now let's look at it from the other side
what do roman catholics say yes about
advertising
about adventism seventh adventists yes
yes
isn't that important definitely okay so
we've now cited three documents that
people can read at their leisure because
we're not going to discuss them in
detail we've summarized them
but what we really want to know is how
do
the catholics or how does the roman
catholic system
regard seventh-day adventists
and here is an article in catholic
answers
on seventh-day adventism and there is
the webpage
and i think we should be a little bit
more thorough when it comes to this one
correct
so let's just briefly go through this
article and then we can see
what the situation is
most people know little about the
seventh-day adventists beyond that they
worship on saturday
not sunday but there's more to this
unique sect
and then they start off with the history
and
they immediately climb into
william miller the millerite movement
which was not adventist right it was a
movement
that eventually embraced the entire
evangelical world
the seventh-day adventist church traces
its route to the
american preacher william miller a
baptist who predicted the second coming
would occur
between march 21 1843 and march 21
1844 because he and his followers
proclaimed christ's
imminent advent they were known as
adventists they weren't known as
seventh-day adventists they were known
as
adventists and they were accustomed to
keeping the first day of the week
so when christ failed to appear miller
reluctantly endorsed the position of a
group of his followers
known as the seventh month movement
who claimed christ would return on
october 22
1844 that's in the seventh month of the
jewish calendar
when this didn't happen either miller
for swore predicting the date of the
second coming
and his followers broke up into a number
of competing
factions now this is roman catholicism
they know about seventh-day
adventism and they're giving this
history
and they will not be very flattering
when it comes to this history
so he did not adhere to any
of their theories after that so miller
had claimed
based on the interpretation of daniel in
revelation that christ would return
1843 to 1844
to cleanse the sanctuary and
it was thought that the sanctuary was
the earth they had
no idea of the heavenly sanctuary at
that stage
but we've spoken about that in a
previous what's up so i'm not going to
go
into the details
then another group of millerites was
influenced by a man called joseph bates
who in 1846
and 1849 issued pamphlets insisting that
christians observe
the jewish sabbath
saturday by the way
is there such a thing as a jewish
sabbath
no it's not sabbath it's god's sabbath
was it not instituted in eden in genesis
and was there a jew around no nope
so it's god's sabbath so this is a
basically derogatory terminology that
they're using
to belittle this particular sabbath
so the two streams of thought christ
entering the heavenly sanctuary and the
need to keep the jewish
sabbath were combined by ellen
gould white
now this also is of course
a distortion so what happened
is when he didn't come to the earth they
did bible studies
and they discovered that the sanctuary
that was to be cleansed was the heavenly
sanctuary yes
now you know martin we don't have to go
into all the details but if you go into
the book of daniel and the book of
daniel
is pivotal it's a very important book
and before we discuss that any further
i'd like to ask you a question
is god the author of confusion no
okay can i ask you another question is
god the author of the bible
yes through the prophets right yes
okay uh did god promise to preserve his
book
yes he did right
did he uh proclaim a curse on anyone who
adds or subtracts from it
yes okay does he ex
expect us to believe the word
man does not live by word by bread alone
but by every word that proceeds out of
the mouth
of the lord another question
uh can god hold us responsible
for not keeping the word if he did not
preserve the word
no are you sure
yeah because then you don't have
anything to go on there's no basis
exactly so in other words inspiration
without preservation is totally useless
yes
so we have to assume that god
preserved his word
now the position of the protestant world
when it was started under martin luther
and the reformers was that
all doctrine was to be based on the word
of god and that that was the norm and
the standard
rome of course opposed that idea right
yes
and later on the higher critics
which have their origin in the stable of
rome
started to dissect the word of god and
say that this wasn't there in the
original
and that wasn't relevant and this is an
allegory and
that is a manufactured
portion that was added by this that and
the other
making the bible a disjointed
basically allegorical storybook
now if you want to read the bible like
that then
then you have the right to do that but
if you choose to believe the word of god
then you are bound by the word of god
isn't that correct yeah
so we have two ideologies here so
christ entering the heavenly sanctuary
he says this was an idea
that was combined by ellen g white
so did the earthly
priest enter the earthly sanctuary
yes and he was a type of christ
yes did christ therefore enter into a
heavenly sanctuary
yes what does the book of hebrews say
about that exactly we have a high priest
who
went into the heavenly right yes
and what does he do there he's
interceding on our behalf right yes
so that's biblical this sounds as
if some insane person thought this up
they're totally disregarding the bible
here
okay so let's continue
they talk about adventist propaganda
white claimed to receive the first
several hundred visions
in december 1844
she gained recognition in adventist
circles as a prophetess
and became a chur the church's leader
again that is a distortion yes
she did claim to be even
more than a prophetess and we've
discussed that before
we've discussed the lesser and the
greater light in the what's up series
people can have a look at it
and we stand by it because
all the criteria that apply biblically
to a prophet
apply to this person right
so she was not the church leader
there were leaders that were chosen and
she was part of the team yes
correct her most important books
especially
the desire of ages and the great
controversy are
frequently reprinted by seventh-day
adventist publishing houses in a variety
of formats they often appear
with different covers and titles
and then they say
adventists have always been regarded
suspiciously by evangelicals
now we we read that statement that the
other
churches will
not look on adventists with a favorable
eye
correct so here they acknowledge
that that is indeed the case
so actually it's a fulfillment of
prophecy right
yes yes considering them a fanatical
cult
many evangelical leaders even have
asserted and then they say
interestingly incorrectly that
adventists are not christian
even though they believe in christ's
divinity and use a valid trinitarian
form of baptism
okay now what about adventist beliefs
they say that seventh-day adventists
agree with many catholic doctrines
including the trinity
we will see that the adventist view on
the trinity
differs from that of the catholics so
they are not right there they are using
one word
and applying criteria that are not
necessarily true
right christ's divinity
yes we believe in christ's divinity
the virgin birth yes we believe in that
the atonement
yes we believe in the atonement but not
the catholic version of the atonement
correct
because in the catholic version christ
never died
for you whereas in the protestant
version
he died for you
so those are things that they mention
the physical resurrection of the dead
yes they believe in that
christ's second coming they believe in
that they use
valid a valid form of baptism
they believe in original sin excuse me
we do not believe in the doctrine of the
original sin
as proclaimed by the roman catholic
church
where you inherit the sin of adam
no we inherit according to the scripture
the sinful nature
so that is not a correct statement and
reject the evangelical teaching that one
can never lose one's salvation no matter
what one does
that is they correctly reject once saved
always saved
so that paragraph has some truth and
some error in it right
unfortunately they also hold many false
and strange doctrines that's important
that people understand this
we've already seen many errors in this
document yes
now this has been where your ears must
speak up
yes if they say this is with strange and
false doctrines coming this is what you
will be held accountable then for
exactly
so what are these strange and false
doctrines among these
are the following the catholic church is
the [__] of babylon
it's not only the adventist church that
says that
martin luther said it all the reformers
said it
all the protestant churches believed it
before
they capitulated in the economical
movement correct
so this is not a false teaching
because the prophet daniel who they
will denigrate
also says so yes i mean if you read
daniel chapter 7 and you take the book
romanism and the reformation
they will tell you that it fits like one
of chubb's keys
the lock and absolutely refuses to fit
any other organization but the roman
catholic church
so it is a biblical statement that
the church of rome is the [__] of
babylon
the pope is the antichrist well martin
luther said it
all the churches believed it until they
capitulated
so they must have turned their back on
the biblical criteria
in the last days sunday worship will be
the mark of the beast
no rome herself has claimed that sunday
is the mark of her
authority yes so again this is
a false way of stating
this issue they say that the adventists
teach that there is a future millennium
in which the devil will roam the earth
while christians are with christ in
heaven
that's not just what the adventists say
that's what the bible says
in the book of revelation so this is
absolutely
straight from the book of revelation and
is biblical
just because rome doesn't believe in a
millennium where the devil will roam on
the earth but they believe in
a millennialism there is no millennium
the church will reign
doesn't make this statement wrong so
again
they say that adventists say that the
soul sleeps between death and the
resurrection
the bible teaches that yes just because
the churches out there do not want to
accept this
but have returned to the doctrinal
position of rome doesn't make this wrong
martin luther believed in seoul sleep
tindall believed in self-sleep and the
early church
believed in this but they refused to put
it in their catechism
because they preferred the false
doctrine of rome
that you are a
disembodied spirit when you are dead
so again this is what the bible teaches
then they also mention here the doctrine
of hell
which adventism according to the book of
revelation
refers to as the second death the
destruction by fire
so again when you look at what is
supposedly false doctrines here these
are biblical doctrines that they are
condemning
because they are condemning the bible
exactly
exactly adventists also
pre-subscribe to the two protestant
chipolets sola scriptira the bible
is the sole rule of faith and sola fide
justification is by faith alone now this
is a very derogatory way of stating it
let me show you the definition of the
word shibalet
quickly here is the definition from the
dictionary and it says
shibboleth a custom principle or belief
distinguishing a particular class or
group of people
especially a long-standing one regarded
as
outmoded or no longer
important so what these people are
saying here is that the two
doctrines namely sola scriptura
and sola fide the bible and the bible
alone
and by faith alone is a shibbolet it's
outdated we don't look
we no longer believe it this is
an absolute travesty
it goes against the plainest teaching of
the bible
by faith you are saved and
not through works by grace right yeah
correct
unbelievable so this tells us
that the roman catholic church is not a
biblical church
when they deny these obvious
very distinct doctrines
other protestants especially
conservative evangelicals and
fundamentalists often attack adventists
on these points claiming they do not
really hold them
which is often used as proof that they
are a cult
what the other churches are doing is
saying that adventists say you have to
obey god's commandments yes so they
say we are works based the work's based
but the keeping of the commandments is a
culmination of your faith and not a
means to salvation
if you love me keep my commandments he
who says he loves me and keeps not my
commandments he's a liar
and the truth is not in him so
whether the adventists are decried as a
cult by
the evangelicals because they keep the
commandments
or whether they are decried as a cult by
the catholics because they subscribe to
sola scriptura and sola fide
doesn't make the adventists wrong it
makes the others unbiblical
but then i will agree with paulia
who said if by their definition that is
what makes it a cult then i'm happy to
be part of a cult
then i'm also part of the cult
absolutely
now let's just continue
they say here catholics may suppose that
anti-catholicism is part of
advertising's
radical fringe unfortunately this is
untrue adventists who are moderate
on catholicism are a minority
anti-catholicism characterizes the
denomination
because it is embraced in whites
divinely
inspired writings there's a heavy note
of sarcasm
there a few illustrations help
indicate the scope of the problem
and then they proceed to quote the
writings of ellen g
white as to why
the roman catholic church is babylon the
great the mother of harlots
and she's very direct yes as was martin
luther as was
tyndall as was melanton
as was every reformer she's in very
very good company doesn't make her a
false prophet
so we don't have to read them all but
she clearly says that the pope
is the antichrist it comes out of great
controversy you can just go and read it
there
yes bear in mind that these quotes are
not taken from an
obscure work of whites that nobody ever
reads
they are from what is probably a single
most popular volume the great
controversy
so they are fully aware of this do you
think that they
uh are very pleased about this no
no then they have a section on
adventist eschatology seventh-day
adventism is basically consumed with the
concept of the last days
well the bible has a lot to say about
the last days
the book of revelation warns us as to
precisely what is going to happen in the
last days
and jesus christ admonishes us to study
the book of daniel
and there's a special blessing on those
that study the book of revelation yes
so would you not want to be consumed
with that
definitely very well so we can
glimpse over that section
and then i have this interesting
statement seventh-day adventism cannot
change its views on the catholic church
being the [__] of babylon
without admitting that it was wrong on
sunday worship
it cannot admit that sunday worship is
not the mark of the beast
without changing its view on the jewish
sabbath
seventh-day adventism cannot cease to be
anti-catholic without
ceasing to be seventh-day adventism
they are spot-on yeah they are spot-on
as far as that statement is concerned so
if we reject the adventist view
that rome is the antichrist then we
reject the reformers view
in other words if the reformed churches
have changed their stance
regarding this issue it is not the
adventist church that is apostate in
this regard
it is the reformed churches that have
given up their roots
yes the very reason why they were
protesting by virtue of their valid
baptism
and their belief in christ's divinity
and in the doctrine of the trinity
which by the way is not the same as the
catholic one right
because we serve a personal god and not
a pantheistic one correct
seventh-day adventists are christians
that's very kind of them
but christians once separated from the
church our lord founded
are susceptible to being tossed to and
fro and carried about by every wind of
doctrine
saying basically they're saying give up
your doctrines
come back to the fold and give up your
faith in the word of god and
accept our traditions and we will accept
you yeah
that's what they're basically saying and
basically we can say to the evangelical
world
give up your protestant faith and give
up your solar scripture
and give up your solar feeder and then
you can be in the economical movement
with rom
correct that's exactly how
so yes my question is this who's the
only consistent protestant that's left
did you know that rome actually says
that yes
rome says that the seventh-day
adventists are the only consistent
protestants
yes it's amazing right correct
and they also say that if you really
want to be a protestant
then you should keep saturday holy and
become a seventh-day adventist yeah
they say that exactly like that exactly
like that
so having having uh discussed this and
why would they say that
because it's the truth and because they
know who's their enemy
they know exactly who the final enemy is
so do you think they want to
uh give them some special attention
definitely very well
so now martin let's jump to
modern times to current events
yeah because now we've seen how rome
views adventists seventh-day adventists
correct
and they hinted as to how the
evangelicals see
adventists right correct because in
those points
where the evangelicals do not
believe as the bible says they differ
from adventists
and in the quotes that we started off
with we saw
that at seventh the adventists were not
a very
visible group group but it
also said they would become more visible
in the end correct now what was it in
that article that
seemed to irk them the most the fact
that
the adventists proclaim as did
the reformers that rome is the
antichrist
they are also a little bit irked about
the view
that prior to the millennium
christ will return and destroy
all who do not come into harmony
with those who keep the commandments of
god
and have the faith of jesus so the
commandments of god and the sabbath
issue will become a very prominent one
so this is a terrible bone of contention
because it's a question of whose
authority
is now at stake if you keep the sabbath
you are saying the bible is my authority
scripture if you keep the sunday you are
saying
rome is your authority yes so it's a
clash of authorities right
so these articles that we will now
discuss
uh have been discussed on other forums
as well
but they're very important so let's just
look at them
this is a the daily beast and it talks
about
how a new religion could rise from the
ashes of q anon
now what's that got to do with adventism
right
there he has talked that if the past
taught us anything
it is that failed prophecies and
frustrated predictions don't always mark
the beginning of the end
for radical social movements
radical political social
movements there's these buzz words that
you
pick up we've read in the previous one
extremists
in that one fundamentalist
cult sect now we just look for those
words again
and then they jumped from q anon
to the new york farmer
bap and baptist preacher william miller
now what is william miller got to do
with q anon
preached that the return of jesus christ
was imminent
his prophecy was based largely on his
study of the biblical book of
daniel that's very important his
interpretation
led him to conclude initially at least
that christ would return sometime
between march 18
30 43 and 1844 when march 1844
passed without the appearance of christ
and his angels
in the sky miller picked another date
april 18 1844
which also slid by without cosmic
incident
or divine intervention a follower of
miller samuel snow
proposed the third date in october but
the day of judgment had still
not arrived so the millerites were
disillusioned
continues down here one group began to
argue that they were only partly wrong
the prophecies weren't about the second
coming and the end of the world but
rather about the cleansing of the
heavenly sanctuary
now the prophecy in daniel clearly
stated
that the sanctuary would be cleansed yes
but they didn't have a good view of what
the sanctuary was
but the bible has
so much to say on the sanctuary that
this is a truth that had to be
rediscovered yes and there were reasons
why god permitted it and god permitted
it
and i think god permitted it even
for the final attack that is going to
come upon god's people
so they say it wasn't an earthly invent
it was a heavenly one
and this explained why to us mere humans
it might appear that nothing had
happened so there's a
certain hint of sarcasm in there
it was out of this group that
seventh-day adventist
church arose
ironically the prophecies in daniel that
formed the basis for the millerite and
many other prophecies about the end of
the world were themselves the product of
dashed expectations
though it is set in the 6th century bc
daniel was written during the reign of
the seleucid king
antiochus epiphanes4 175-164 bc
in other words what these people are
saying is
that daniel never wrote the book yes
right that's exactly what they said they
are saying that because
they are dating the writing of the book
more than 400 years later
so where does that come from that comes
from the higher critics
that tried to bring the book of daniel
into disrepute
and this is saying that god never
preserved his writings and that his
writings
are not trustworthy this is the roman
catholic view
yes and it is totally incorrect
correct because even the dead sea
scrolls
have provided evidence that the book of
daniel is authentic
because the portions where changes from
aramaic
to hebrew are included in those
portions that were found of the book of
daniel
and that aramaic the dialect used comes
from persian times
and not from greek times as they claim
over here so the book of daniel is
authentic
to the time period that the bible says
and
not what these critics are saying
so we as seventh-day adventists take the
book of daniel
as authentic and a prophecy from god
great martin luther did the same yep
martin luther said this is the first
book
of the old testament that i will
translate
because everybody has to know it because
out of the book of daniel
they found the key that unlocked
revelation
and they found the identity of the
antichrist
in daniel chapter 7. correct and by the
way
in daniel chapter 7 it clearly states
that jesus christ
came to the ancient of days and not
to this earth so they do not understand
their bibles
and and they denigrate the bible correct
and they also
that antiochus is for they make
the guy that was the antichrist yes
now that's preterism now this is how
confused they are
they make antiochus epiphanes for the
antichrist
who was a greek king but the book of
daniel tells us he comes out of the
fourth kingdom which is roman not greece
so it cannot be antiochus epiphanes
and then the other jesuit doctrine is
that he comes in the future
after the church is raptured neither of
those two
are biblical all this comes out of the
stall of rome
absolutely so this is very interesting
and the way in which it is written tells
me
that these people had some help
and seeing the doctrine that is being
proclaimed here i wouldn't be surprised
if the finger of a jesuit is involved in
the writing of this article
or at least the influence i cannot say
for sure i do not know
the dates are very specific and after
the first date for the restoration of
the temple given in daniel 8
12 passed without incident a later
author was forced to add a second
prophecy daniel 12 11 to
12 to account for the mistake this is an
absolute distortion yes but we've dealt
with daniel chapter 7 we're not going to
deal with it
it is blatantly clear who the antichrist
is
and when he shall and like he just said
what they just said now
is that you can have no confidence in
the book of the
in the bible because one of his books is
a total mess up
correct there's another article
how q anon uses religion to lure
unsuspecting christians this is a
totally different article
and the fbi has called q a non a
domestic
terror threat and an internal fbi
memo want that fringe conspiracy
theories
very likely motivate some domestic
extremists
wholly or in part to commit criminal and
sometimes
violent activity so here again
in this article they show how q anon is
a conspiracy
theory based organization that was based
on false prophecies that never came true
and immediately they do the same thing
as the previous article
they link it to the millerite movement
and therefore to the seventh day
advocate
and here's another article how cults
like q anon
respond to embarrassing failures
and immediately they link it to the
great disappointment
of october 22 1844 on the miller right
movement
yeah now this has been shown by other
ministries as well but
this is really very very important for
the time that we are living in
so anybody who has according to them
failed prophecies
belongs into the category of conspiracy
theories right
and you can almost say
domestic terrorists correct because
that's where they bring the link in the
whole time correct
now you know what's fascinating to me
martin many years ago
a prominent adventist
evangelist actually made a statement
where he said that the terrorism laws
that have been introduced against
extreme islamic organizations
are actually designed in his opinion
for a final assault on seventh-day
adventism
and i agree with him i believe
exactly the same what was good for the
goose will
eventually be thought good for the
gander
as well so we don't have to go into all
the details
we just see that these connections are
very clearly made
and the mellorite movement and
seventh-day adventism
is being brought into focus yes
into prominence so now
what do we have to do as a consequence
there's a vast difference between the
conspiracy theories of q and on
and the so-called false prophecies
of seventh-day adventists those so
called false prophecies are based on
very sound biblical criteria
q anon did not use a specific bible
prophecy
in order to base their criteria on they
used verses
in the bible yes about the social
decline
and that retribution would come but
seventh-day adventism doesn't rely
on some figure called q
or whatever to come and solve the
problem
no seventh-day adventism is rooted in
the
in the faith that jesus christ himself
yes
himself will intervene yes
it's because they're expecting an
earthly kingdom
and the thousand years of peace on earth
yes
that's contrary to what adventists
believe what the biblical
teaching is that it will be in heaven
the thousands jesus christ will come
every eye will see him he will separate
the wicked from the just
it's very clear in the bible the man of
sin will be destroyed by the brightness
of his coming
yeah that's what the bible teaches so
these are the things that are now
becoming prominent in the news so
we need to understand exactly where we
stand
all right here's another article in the
atlantic the prophecies of
q american conspiracy theories are
entering a dangerous
new phase and we don't have to go
through the
entire thing but again they linked it to
william miller
the millerites became the adventists and
as q anon had false prophecies so the
adventist movement has false prophecies
and they cannot be rehabilitated
that is fascinating here is another one
q anon took a major hit with biden's
election but it's
never going away again
they refer to the seventh-day adventists
that are direct descendants of those
that had the prophecy wrong
no they had an explanation to the
prophecy wrong but that doesn't make the
prophecy wrong
so martin if this is what is going to be
used against seventh-day adventism
that those who claim that rome is the
antichrist
and that any movement where church and
state comes together
is a system that christ will condemn
particularly when it starts making laws
contrary to god's law
then that movement must be eradicated if
they want to set up their
kingdom of peace so the adventists will
become
prominent my question is is the news
media
beginning to make them prominent
definitely
too many they might be an obscure group
yeah are they
going to become a group that's not so
obscure
we don't have to read the whole article
but again they talk about the great
disappointment
stating they got the prophecies wrong
etc etc
and last year we had this article in the
catholic
herald where they claimed that ellen g
white
was the heretic of the week
and they also had other heretics
like william tyndall and martin luther
so she was again a good company
she was in good company so i'm so happy
that martin luther
was also a heretic and
you will remember that when we discussed
this article
we also referred to a sermon of mine
which was called bookends
as to exactly what the definition of a
heretic is
and according to the bible the greatest
heretic is the roman catholic system
so people put a link in again to that
one i know we are
stirring the pot here no but that's very
important let's do that
so again they run down the debacle of
miller in 1844
martin are you sure that the 1844
prophecy was a correct prophecy and not
a false prophecy
yes even though the event
was different to what they expected yeah
when you study this whole
scenario you get to the crux of it and
it makes sense
but let's just read this paragraph in
this article
talking about ellen white who they're
not very happy with of course
her ongoing revelations formed the basis
of the doctrine upon which she
and her husband james founded the
seventh-day
adventist church so called because
white claimed that christ wanted to be
worshipped on the jewish
sabbath that's a ridiculous statement
but let's leave it at that
these doctrines included the revival of
jewish dietary customs
although most adventists are vegetarian
today
identification of the pope as antichrist
three separate divine persons rather
than the orthodox
doctrine of trinity and several
other unique teachings so they admit
that
the adventist view of the trinity is
definitely not the same as the catholic
view
so martin when we look at the 2
300 day prophecy in the bible
where it says quite clearly
in the book of daniel that from the
issuing of the decree
to restore and rebuild jerusalem
unto messiah the prince and then it
gives
an absolute perfect
perfect time delineation
unto the baptism of jesus christ yes
and it tells you when the prophecy would
begin
with the issuing of the decree of outer
sexes
which was in 457 bc
and the prophecy of the 70 weeks
culminated
in 34 a.d at the stoning
of stephen because
jesus died in the middle of the final
week
three and a half years before the
stoning of stephen
and he said in the middle of the week he
will put an end to
the sacrificial system his death put an
end to the sacrificial system
because he became the great anti-type
the ant
the sacrificial lamb and jesus had said
go ye first to the lost children of
israel
and preach the gospel only to them which
happened
until the time of the stoning of stephen
and then paul was called and peter had a
vision that he must not call the
gentiles unclean
yes and the gospel went to the gentiles
a perfect fulfillment of prophecy
now the evangelicals have swallowed of
course the catholic version
that you take that final week and throw
it into the future and it doesn't affect
god's people at all
which totally obliterates the historic
continuous
form of prophecy that is the only
consistent
protestant interpretation yes
not only that the prophecy continues
unto 2 300 days take a day for a year
which when applied to the 70 weeks works
out
exactly in terms of
the prophetic scenario for the coming of
the messiah
so that prophecy ends in 1844
and they thought that the end of the
world would come then but after studying
the prophecy
and studying the sanctuary issue they
realized
that no the earth had gone into the
phase of judgment
yes and jesus christ was brought in
daniel chapter 7 to the ancient of
days so we have been living
in judgment time since that which they
called the investigative judgment
now people say but that's not biblical
but doesn't jesus say that when he comes
they will he's rewarded with him
doesn't jesus say that he will separate
the good fish from the bad fish yes
so mustn't that judgment precede is
coming so there's nothing wrong
with the investigative judgment right
yeah it's biblical yeah
it's just giving it a title okay so if
that is true and if the book of daniel
stands
then this is immovable now was 1844 just
an ordinary date
in 1844 many things happened
it saw the birth of baha'ism
baha'ism says that all the religions
must come together
as one and anyone that wants to be
separate
doesn't fit into the system so there
must be
a world religion now the united nations
has a tremendous baha'i
representation and the
parliament of world religions is
basically
saying exactly the same thing as
baha'ism all the world religions must
unite as one
one world religion it saw the birth of
communism
exactly on that date is when engels and
and marx came together it's all
the beginning of modern communication
and transport systems the first railway
line
in the united states it saw
the first communication via the mosque
code that made it possible for the
gospel to go to the entire world
it's all the birth of darwinism because
in 1844
darwin wrote his first sketch of the
origin of species
so god is not the creator evolution
becomes the creator
in the same year the roman catholic
pontiff condemns the bible societies
it sees the birth of mormonism which
says that your gods
it sees the birth of spiritism in 1844
the rapping started
and the first modern form of spiritism
came
into the world it sees the birth of
theosophy
lucifer is the true son of god
it sees the discovery of the synthetic
manuscript
codex syntheticus on which all modern
bible translations are based
yes which the reformers rejected but
their children don't
and then it sees the doctrine of the
rapture
and dispensationalism which is a
jesuit doctrine inserted into
protestantism
yes not what the reformers believe it
sees the birth of extensionalism
and the birth of millerism and the
seventh-day adventism
and the sabbath is restored in exactly
the same year
yes so which of these
is based on truth and which of these is
based on fault
i see the only attack is on millerism
and the seventh-day adventists
and all of these are accepted
isn't that strange isn't that strange
let's read what the spirit of prophecy
says about
william muller god directed the mind of
william muller to the prophecies and
gave him great light upon the book of
revelation
if daniel's visions had been understood
the people could better have understood
the visions of
john but at the right time god moved
upon his
chosen servant who with clearness and in
the power of the holy spirit
opened the prophecies and showed the
harmony of the visions of daniel
and john and other portions of the bible
and pressed home upon the hearts of the
people the sacred
fearful warnings of the word to prepare
for the coming of the son of man
deep and solemn conviction rested upon
the minds of those who heard it
and ministers and people sinners and
infidels
turned to the lord and sought the
preparation to stand
in the judgment angels of god
accompanied william miller in his
mission he was
firm and undaunted fearlessly
proclaiming the message committed to his
trust
a world lying in wickedness and a cold
worldly church
were enough to call into action all his
energies
and lead him willingly to endure toil
privation
and suffering although opposed by
professed christians and the world
and buffeted by satan and his angels he
ceased not to preach the everlasting
gospel to crowds wherever he was invited
sounding far and near the cry fear god
and give
glory to him for the hour of his
judgment
is come that's the first angel's message
yes
now martin william miller
preached in the various denominational
churches he preached
totally interdenominational yes it was
not his view to combine
the church to make a new church his
intention was
that the different churches embrace this
new or these prophecies and in
embedded in there absolutely correct
now here's another question he
showed what the prophecy said at least
ministers from different denominations
then studied it and accepted those views
so are they now just william miller's
views or were they the views of
many over a hundred pastors
from the evangelical churches so it was
an evangelical movement
correct correct consisting of all the
denominations virtually in the united
states of america right yes
so is it just william miller who was at
fault here or
were then all those ministers at fault
yeah so why pin it on one man when it
was an entire movement correct
the first angel's message was the hour
of his judgment has come right
this was what miller preached so in
other words what mala was preaching was
once it was understood afterwards that
it wasn't the
cleansing of the earth but that the time
of judgment has come that the earth had
gone
over into the face of the investigative
judgment
who will receive the reward when christ
comes
which is a logical thing i saw the
people of god
joyful in expectation looking for their
lord
but god designed to prove them his hand
covered a mistake in the reckoning of
the prophetic periods
those who were looking for their lord
did not discover this mistake
and the most learned men who opposed the
time also
failed to see it now
they're saying god wouldn't work like
this
did his hand cover a mistake when the
disciples failed to realize what was
going to happen on calvary exactly
did they go through a big a great
disappointment
were those walking on the way to
emeralds
totally dejected totally the sunday
they jesus was coming into jerusalem as
the king
and the friday he was hanging on the
cross and their dreams were shattered
had jesus told them that he was going to
die yes did they see it
no they missed it yes his hand was over
it
now why was it necessary for god to
allow this disappointment
why wouldn't they clear in their minds
as to this issue
because the chaff was separated from
the wheat yes and the dross was
separated
from the silver that's why god permitted
it yeah cleansing it
so only those that saw no mistake
in the biblical reckoning and went back
to study the scriptures
discovered the sanctuary message the
rest just gave up
the rest gave up the same happened in
the days of the disciples
god designed that his people should meet
with a disappointment the time
passed and those who had looked with
joyful expectation for their savior were
sad and disheartened as were
the disciples while those who had not
loved the appearing of jesus
but embraced the message through fear
were pleased
that he did not come at the time of
expectation
their profession had not affected the
heart and purified the life
the passing of time was well calculated
to reveal
such hearts that's exactly what happened
so god had a plan
with this whole thing do you think it
could be part of this plan
that this thing will become prominent
again
so that only those who studied the
scriptures and made
sure that there was no mistake in that
reckoning
will actually say we will not be shaken
yes
it's going to be a re requisite it's
going to be a test again
as it was a test in 1844
so it will become a test at the end of
time
are you sure that you have studied
the prophecy of daniel and believe
that it is from god and not some
author in the time of antiochus
epiphanes 4 as they would have you
believe
and that god is impotent and not capable
of preserving his word
or are you going to stand by sola
scriptura
and solafide
they were the first to turn and ridicule
the sorrowful
disappointed ones who really loved the
appearing of their savior are they doing
the same now to
these organizations that got it wrong
and then pinning it on the seventh-day
adventist yes
i saw the wisdom of god improving his
people and giving them a searching test
to discover those who would shrink and
turn
back in the hour of trial this is
exactly
what it is about
the second angel's message that was to
follow the first right yes
as the churches refused to receive the
first angels message
they rejected the light from heaven and
fell from the favor of god
they trusted in their own strength and
are opposing the first
message placed themselves where they
could not see the light of the second
angel's message
but beloved of god who were oppressed
accepted the message babylon has fallen
and left the churches now martin
this call babylon is fallen is going to
be repeated
yes is it going to be repeated with the
word she's become a house of demons and
of every unclean and hateful bird
yes is it going to be repeated with with
a call
come out of her that you be not
partakers of a sin
now what is the definition of sin martin
transgression of the law
aha so at the end of time
are the churches going to break
god's commandments and his law
yes and that constitutes them as babylon
correct yes so there's another message
coming this is going to be repeated yes
with a very loud voice now
when the churches return to their fold
to rome and unite within organizations
that says there was no atonement that
the priest will forgive your sin
that christ would get sacrificed over
and over and over when the bible clearly
says by one sacrifice he has forever
made perfect
and therefore the bread and the wine are
symbols of a completed act and not
a perpetual sacrifice
if you combine with that organization
that invokes the help of dead people
which is forbidden in the bible don't
you become a partaker of their sin
yes isn't that logical
so if you refuse to accept that that
system is antichrist but is actually
part of the christian world
then you can come a partaker in them
and so this is an appeal to the
christian world
look at what has come into your churches
look at what rituals have come into your
churches
look how the word of god has been
negated
virtually on every page as to what is
morality
what is male what is female
you can go down the list and ask
yourself
are the churches today following the
bible
or are they following social
doctrines yes
near the close of the second angels
message i saw a great light from heaven
shining upon the people of god
the rays of this light seemed bright as
the sun and i heard the voice of the
angels crying behold the bridegroom
cometh go ye out to meet him
this was the midnight cry which was to
give power to the second angel's message
now at the time this message was given
the second angel's message
the churches weren't nearly in the state
that they were in now
so the the bible just said babylon has
fallen
with no details today
the focus is she's not only fallen she
has become a house of demons
and i see one evangelical pastor after
the other
climbing on his pulpit decrying the sins
of the church
and of society yeah and not realize that
the become
part of babylon and have fallen i want
to make an appeal to the pastors out
there
to come out of them my people and keep
the commandments of god and hold to the
testimony of jesus
amen so a spirit of solemn and earnest
prayer was everywhere felt by the saints
a holy solemnity was resting upon them
angels were watching with the deepest
interest the effect of the message and
were elevating those who received it
and drawing them from earthly things to
obtain large
supplies from salvation's fountains
god's people were then accepted of him
jesus looked upon them with pleasure for
his image was reflected in them
they had made a full sacrifice and
entire consecration
and expected to be changed to
immortality but they were destined again
to be
sadly disappointed the people of god
were again proved and tested by the way
were these adventists at that
stage seventh-day adventists no no
no they were all people in their own
churches
exactly the world laughed and mocked and
reproached them
and those who had believed without a
doubt that jesus would ear then
have come to raise the dead and change
the living saints and take the kingdom
to possess it forever
felt as did the disciples at the
sepulcher of christ
they have taken away my lord and i know
not where they have laid
him see the connection the same
disappointment
yes and this is not seventh day
adventists they didn't exist yet
this is an evangelical experience
and god called them together
and those that accepted it realized that
their churches had fallen
and many many many did not heed the call
so god permitted all this time
for the apostasy to become so ripe
that he can say they have become a house
of demons yes
and a house of every unclean and
detestable bird false holy spirit
this was a cleansing time for god's
true church exactly now what does this
false holy spirit teach these people
it teaches them that god is not
concerned about
sin that the law of god has been done
away with when jesus clearly said i have
not come to abolish the law
it teaches them that you can live in
harmony with god
without living in harmony with god's
commandments
it's not logical none of the reformers
said it
but all of these churches say it and
those churches also said it
once when this two angels messages was
going on
it though the other churches also said
it
and that's why these people that
embraced the message
came out of them correct
and then they discovered their mistake
right the sanctuary
through the sacrifice and offering
brought to the earthly sanctuary the
children of israel were to lay hold
of the merits of a savior to come
and in the wisdom of god the particulars
of this work were given us
that we might by looking to them
understand the work of jesus in the
heavenly sanctuary
because the sanctuary would be cleansed
of what
the record of sins
as jesus died on calvary he cried it is
finished and the veil of the temple was
rent in twain from the top to the bottom
this was to show that the service of the
earthly sanctuary was forever
finished and that god would no more meet
with the priests in their earthly temple
to accept their sacrifices
the blood of jesus was then shed which
was to be offered by himself
in the heavenly sanctuary the bible says
he didn't enter with the blood of
sheep and goats but with his own blood
entered what the heavenly sanctuary
absolutely it's biblical
so it's also important to know which
compartment of the heavenly sanctuary
correct
if you read the king james then it's
perfectly clear or if you read
any one of the of the old received text
then it is perfectly clear that he
entered into the holy place
just as the earthly priest also first
entered into the
holy place and then subsequently into
the most holy
but the new translations distort that
now
so again do you believe your bible
do you believe the book of hebrews
if you do then you must be a seventh-day
adventist
it's as simple as that
as the priest entered the most holy once
a year
to cleanse the earthly sanctuary so
jesus
entered the most holy of the heavenly at
the end of the 2300
days because that was the cleansing of
the sanctuary
message there was the ceremony that was
yonkipour
that was the day of atonement to make a
final atonement for all who would be
benefit by his mediation
and thus to cleanse the sanctuary
churches that say that this is a cultic
message
deny the book of hebrews yeah
and then the third angel's message are
they written in the bible
just for decoration
not many people want to read the book of
revelation and this the
three angels messages stand in the book
of revelation
because they say it's a closed book but
the bible say blessed are those who read
the book and understand it right correct
it's a blessing
there's a blessing on it so the third
angel's message
is in the book and the most fearful
condemnation is associated
with this message right so this message
was designed to put the children of god
upon their god
by showing them that the hour of
temptation and anguish that was before
them
said the angel they will be brought into
close combat with the beast
and his image their only hope of eternal
life is to remain steadfast
although their lives are at stake they
must hold fast to the truth
the third angel closes his message thus
here is the patience of the saints here
are they that keep the commandments of
god
and the faith of jesus now this message
it directly involves the beast and his
image
so the united states is uh is part of
this because the image of the beast is
when the united states
comes together with the churches to
enforce
rome's doctrines right and the beast i
mean that was identified even by the
reformers
is roman catholicism so when you speak
against these systems you're not going
to be
very popular right as he repeated these
words he pointed to the heavenly
sanctuary
the minds of all who embrace this
message
are directed to the most holy place
where jesus stands before the ark
making his final intercession for all
those for whom mercy still lingers
and for those who have ignorantly broken
the law of god
so this atonement is made for the
righteous dead as well as for the
righteous living
it includes all who died trusting in
christ but who not having received the
light upon god's commandments
had sinned ignorantly in transgressing
its precepts
there are millions of people in the past
who were good believing christians
who never knew about the sunday sabbath
issue
they should have known yeah it was part
of the battle of the reformation
and karlstadt who was with martin luther
plainly taught that the sabbath should
be kept
and many many of the reformers stated
that the sabbath should be kept
but even protestants persecuted them so
they've had many opportunities
the valdensis kept the sabbath the
albiganses
kept the sabbath there were many many
groups that refused to give up the
sabbath
they should have known but they did not
know and god
because they were not informed
overlooked their ignorance right after
jesus
opened the door of the most holy the
light of the sabbath was seen
because if you go to the book of
revelation it clearly says
and the ark of the covenant was seen now
that means the law was
being made planned so after 1844
this final message babylon has fallen
and come back into harmony with god's
law
was being preached so from 1844
this message is the final message of
warning
to come into harmony with god's law
correct
all those the first two angel messages
were getting these people out and
cleansing god's church
and bringing them to here where now
the laws of god the commandments became
a part of the final movement and what do
the churches teach
the the law is not important it's been
done away with
what does rome teach i've changed the
law and you'll keep my changed law
and god says no my law never changes i
do not alter what goes out of my mouth
right so it's a simple choice so after
he opened the door of the most holy this
became very prominent so the sabbath
was seen because if you look at the
tables
there it stands yes you can't take it
away
and as the children of israel were
tested anciently
to see if they would keep god's law i
saw the third angel pointing upward
showing the disappointed ones the way to
the holiest of the heavenly sanctuary
as they by faith entered the most holy
they find jesus
and hope and joy spring up anew
i saw them looking back reviewing the
past from the proclamation of the second
advent of jesus
down through their experience to the
passing of the time in 1844
they see their disappointment explained
and joy
and certainty again animate them the
third angels has lighted up the past
present and future and they know that
god has indeed led them by his
mysterious
providence so basically martin
what was the test in 1844 becomes a test
again and the sabbath will play
a pivotal role because it will determine
do you stand with the commandments of
god or do you stand with the
commandments
of men now martin there are a number of
issues that are important here
we've seen that the doctrinal position
that the seventh-day adventists hold
was not just a seventh-day adventist
position
it was an evangelical position of
many many leaders of the evangelical
churches
that has been established
the new world situation wants to bring
about
a common system
that will accommodate everyone for the
sake of the common good
and therefore all those
that want to be exclusive are
really a problem for this system
so there's more involved than just
seventh-day adventism
anybody who wants to cling to this
concept
that there is only one way to salvation
it's going to be a problem and therefore
there will be an attack on the entire
christian fabric
which will serve again to sift the
christian
fabric and hopefully bring them to the
point
where they will search the scriptures
to see whether that which the ultimate
target which is
in my opinion seventh-day adventist
because that's what the bible says
those who keep the commandments and hold
to the testament
whether that position is sound or not
so it's not enough to suff just
this group that keeps the commandments
and holds to the testimony
you have to really shake the entire
christian fabric
to wake them up again because they are
asleep
so let's see what fox news prime time
had to say on some of these issues
former congresswoman kelsey gabbard from
hawaii democrat joins us now
congresswoman great to see you uh i know
you just been out of the job for a week
or two are you surprised that pushing
forward with this
extra surveillance on would-be domestic
terror
it's so dangerous you know as you guys
have been talking about this is an issue
that all democrats republicans
independents libertarians should be
extremely concerned about especially
because we don't have to guess
about where this goes or how this ends
when you have people like former cia
director john brennan
openly talking about how he's spoken
with
or heard from appointees and nominees in
the biden administration who are already
starting to look across our country
for these types of movements similar to
the insurgencies they've seen overseas
that in his words he says make up this
unholy alliance of
religious extremists racists
bigots he lists a few others and adds at
the end
even libertarians so
when you look at their process and they
start looking at okay how do what
characteristics are we looking for as
we're building this profile
of a potential extremist what are we
talking about religious extremists are
we talking about
uh christians evangelical christians
what is it what is a religious extremist
is it somebody who's pro-life i mean
what
where do you where do you take this uh
you start looking at
okay well obviously you have to be a
white person obviously
likely male libertarians well if anybody
who loves freedom
liberty maybe has an american flag
outside their house or
people who you know attended a trump
rally
once you start walking this down the
path you see where it leads
to a very dangerous undermining of our
civil liberties
our freedoms in our constitution and a
targeting of almost half of the country
there are people who are radicalized
right now
and it is going to take a very long time
and it's going to take a long time and a
lot of effort
um to de-radicalize those people we have
um there are millions of americans um
almost all white almost all republicans
who somehow need to be deprogrammed
they're it's as if they don't they they
are members of a cult the trumpet cult
how are we going to really almost
deprogram these people who have signed
up
for the cult of trump
martin that was very interesting so now
if you supported certain ideologies that
trump espoused
then you are part of a cult and they
have to be deprogrammed
but it seems that these people that are
opining
this kind of view are perfectly fine
who determined that they are perfectly
fine and the others or not
they did right yes so depending on
majorities or whatever
ideologies you can be
within the ambit or on the fringe or on
the outside right
yeah and you again yeah extremists
and fundamentalists
there's another article from wikipedia
sing-yang re-education camps now this is
how they're being used in
china and they're a little bit more
radical
they they collected all
the radical according to them muslim
community
and put them in re-education camps
now could something similar happen in
the western world well
in the video that they looked at earlier
they were talking about
deprogramming people this terrorists
that have to be
looked out and well these camps that
they use in china
for re-education i think it can become a
reality
absolutely so yeah they use them for the
muslims since
2017 local authorities are reportedly
holding hundreds of thousands
of yugos in these camps as well as
members of other ethnic minority groups
for the stated purpose of countering
extremism and terrorism and that is the
point
and that was the same language that they
used now didn't the pope
say that religious fundamentalists are
terrorists
and that fundamentalists are dangerous
yes and what's the definition of a
fundamentalist
a fundamentalist is someone who believes
the bible
and we've just demonstrated that the
seventh-day adventist doctrine
takes the bible at its word and the
roman catholic
version takes the bible
and totally destroys its
its relevance so it's again
a question of who do you believe
as of 2019 it was estimated that chinese
authorities may have
detained one and a half million people
mostly of this muslim group
to re-educate them
i hope that i will be able
to resist a re-education when it comes
to believing the word of god
in the middle ages didn't the
catholic church the roman catholic
church
want to re-educate the protestants
by torturing and all of those they had
the inquisition
what was that you had to recant you had
to recant what is what you believe
exactly that's what they really wanted
you to be re-educated
correct that's what they did and they
did it by force and torture
and by the way one of the methods that
were used by the inquisition was
waterboarding
has the united states used waterboarding
to
re-educate extremists
yes could the same happen again are we
heading back to an
inquisitorial situation
here's an article in the new york post
aoc
proposes funding to deprogram white
supremacists
it's interesting how these freshmen as
trump used to call them are the standard
and the norm for society
and those who are rooted in biblical
principles or brushed aside
as as conspiracy theorists conspiracy
theorists and dangerous people to
society
the world has really been turned upside
down
but the bible says that the children
will rule
and they are
jobiden orders review of u.s domestic
extremism threat this is from
23rd of january this is very new
the national intelligence office was
created after the september 11
2001 attacks we showed in the last ones
how far these preparations have come
and how the anti-terrorism legislation
has been introduced
every time after a disaster yes and now
that that threat is
is gone what is that legislation going
to be used for
so the national intelligence office was
created after the september 11 2001
attacks on the world trade center with
the goal of thwarting
international terrorism the fact that
they are leading the investigation
could suggest that u.s authorities are
examining how to pivot towards a
focus on violence from extremists
at home representative
adam schiff democratic chair of the
house intelligence committee said
it was critical that the biden
administration appeared to be
prioritizing the threat of domestic
terrorism
in particular far right white
supremacist
extremism nurtured on
online platforms has become one of the
most dangerous threats to our nation
schiff said current fbi director chris
wray said last fall that in recent years
the most
lethal violence has come from
anti-government activists
such as anarchists and far-right wing
militia
members now
it's really puzzling to me how they can
put adventism into this
category correct firstly adventism
is probably the most anti-racial
organization that modern world
has ever seen from the beginning
adventism has been absolutely assertive
on the fact that
all people are created equal before god
and that there is no difference by one
blood he has created
all people to be
a racist when you believe that jesus
christ
died for all is bigotry of the highest
order
so how can you even place this
organization
with its multicultural footprint
into this category there must be a plan
there must be a plan newsweek reports
that over 16
000 christians want franklin graham
fired for helping
incite capital riot so here is a
conservative
evangelical christian is he being
targeted
yes absolutely and who's targeting him
well
they call themselves a christian group
uh-huh so is it possible
that these nominal christians
will attack those that have strong views
on
christianity and salvation yes
here's a quote from alice a bailey
now we must understand martin that alice
a bailey
is probably the prophet the prophetess
of the united nations
she comes from the stable of theosophy
following in the footsteps of helena
petrovna blavatsky
where lucifer is the true god now this
organization
forms the basis of these
organizations that are part and parcel
of the united nations
so this is what they believe thus the
expressed aims and efforts of the united
nations will
be eventually brought to fruition and a
new church of god
gathered out of all religions and
spiritual groups
will unitedly bring to an end the great
heresy of separateness
that's a fascinating statement come
out and be separate yes against
uh you cannot be saved alone correct
by the power of the pope so we have two
statements in juxtaposition
love unity and the risen christ will be
present and he will demonstrate to us
the perfect life now this risen christ
is not jesus christ
this is the new age christ
robert muller who was a very prominent
figure
in the united nations is accredited with
the new education
says the world's major religions must
speed up dramatically their economical
movement and recognize the unity of
their objectives in the diversity of
their cults
religions must actively cooperate to
bring to
unprecedented heights a better
understanding of the mysteries of life
and of our place in the universe my
religion
right or wrong and my nation right or
wrong
must be abandoned forever in the
planetary age
donald trump did he stand for
nationalism
yes does president biden stand for
no no so my nation right or wrong
must be abandoned forever in the
planetary age
there's only a global collective
my religion right or wrong must be
abandoned
so if you want to say there's no other
way under heaven and earth whereby you
may be saved except
by jesus christ jesus
must that position be abandoned yes
yes now democratic vice presidential
nominee for the 1984 and executive
director of the world
future society barbara marx hubbard
doesn't mince words when she informs us
humanity will not be able to make the
transition
from earth only to universal life
until the chaff has separated from the
wheat
no worldly peace can prevail until the
self-centered
members of the planetary body either
change
or die that is the choice
they must surely die or change
this act is as horrible as killing a
cancer cell
it must be done for the sake of the
future of the whole
for the common good now not only
hubbard said that but thomas aquinas
said exactly the same thing
it's part of roman catholic doctrine
they have always been defective seeds in
the past they were permitted to die a
natural death
we the elders have been patiently
waiting until the very last
moment before the quantum transformation
to take action to cut out this corrupted
and corrupting
element in the body of humanity it is
like watching a cancer grow
something must be done before the whole
body
is destroyed didn't the pope
decry fundamentalism as just such a
disease
and terrorism must be rooted out
and speaking against rome has also been
defined as an act of terrorism
and dr adler chairman of the board of
editors of the encyclopedia britannica
incorporation director of the institute
for
philosophical research in chicago
chairman
of the padea project and honorary
trustee of the aspen institute
has the following to say simply stated
aldo argues that we will not be able to
attain
world peace until we attain
cultural unity but adler argues that
there is only
one obstacle to this unity
christianity ada's point is simply
christianity claims supernatural
knowledge and divine revelation
that is divisive and not open to
rational debate
should not be tolerated now
that sermon of mine that you will add
the link
yes bookends talks about
divisiveness and whether jesus was
divisive
or whether he was not so remember that
i have to look at that matthew fox i
mean he's a very
prominent person he speaks of the new
age
with its four billion occupants
where the other billions have they been
eliminated
are we heading towards a
deagle.com situation
i understand from some sources that that
information has changed or been removed
yeah i haven't verified that i haven't
verified that but
they certainly said that the christian
nations will suffer
a depopulation
interesting to me author
john randolph price author of the super
beings plainly identifies christians in
this statement
there are some groups who continue to
cling to the absurd
idea that man is a miserable sinner
and worm of the dust
he also notifies us that two and one
half
billion people will be killed that's
exactly
the same thing yeah and new agent
humanist
john dunphy refers to christianity as a
rotting corpse
it seems that true christianity is under
attack
and it must be particularly so for those
in christianity who keep the
commandments
of god rather than the dictates of man
which obviously doesn't make them fit
into society
and therefore are a cancer that must be
removed now here's another
interesting uh discussion on this
uh cbn news channel let's listen to it
big tech free speech is this just a
momentary blip on the radar screen rod
or
do you expect this will get worse oh no
this is definitely going to get worse
and
my book lived not by lies i talk about
this as the beginning of soft
totalitarianism soft totalitarianism
because it's not going to have
gulags and secret police the things that
the soviets had
rather this is something that's going to
be done by
mostly by big tech limiting access to
the economy and keeping it so that only
those who conform with what the regime
wants can participate in the economy
we're already seeing it happen now in
china with the social credit system
there
which only lets people who conform to
what the government wants
have access full access to the economy
and travel
good jobs universities etc i think we
are going to see an
informal version of that happen right
here in america and the hammer is going
to come down on conservatives
and traditional christians so what do
you think will happen in the days ahead
with the joe biden presidency now you
mentioned
soft totalitarianism are we advancing
down that road under joe what do you
expect
yeah we absolutely are joe biden has
already talked about how he's going to
pass domestic terrorism legislation
we're going to see people designated as
terrorists
people who have no interest in terrorism
at all who do not support violence but
who simply
question the way things are done in this
country and they do it so from the right
i believe that christians conservative
christians are going to be targeted too
and there will be no discrimination
between us peaceful
uh conservative christians and those who
want violence but here's an important
point too gary
it's not simply going to come from the
government and may not mostly come from
the government
it's going to come from big business and
big tech
who will be using their freedom in our
free market society
to marginalize and oppress deplorables
which include
political conservatives and religious
conservatives well we've even seen some
of that already
uh with the kova 19 pandemic if you're
if you are against wearing a mask you
become ostracized on big t by big tech
they'll even shut you down so how does
the pandemic play into all of this
well what the pandemic has done and i
should say that i believe the pandemic
is real but what the pandemic has done
is accustomed to us to being controlled
it has kept put us in a position and a
mindset of fear
and control and where we can be
open to being told what to do by the
government and
i think that this has been a dry run if
you will
for uh for greater control and i think
that
insofar as christians have not used this
time this pandemic time to prepare
ourselves
for the long run for what it would mean
to be faithful under a long
period of oppression then we have wasted
our time there's no more time to waste
well more on that than uh rod as we wrap
this up
then how should conservatives and
christians catholics evangelicals in
this country
respond to all this what do we need to
do
well i think the first thing we need to
do is root ourselves as firmly as
possible
in our faith and in community i was
talking last night to an ex-military
intelligence
man a christian who said that no
christian should believe that anything
we say
online or electronically mediated
is safe it will be stored somewhere it
sounds paranoid but it's not paranoid
this is in my book live not by
lies what we have to do most of all
though is prepare to suffer
we in the american church know nothing
about suffering we've had it good for a
long time
the people who grew up under communism
in i talked to in my book live not by
lies
they know what it's like to suffer for
the faith we have to start learning from
their experience and be prepared to be
steadfast
and to suffer without hating our enemy
what's your opinion on that martin i
think the bible tells the same story as
that
what he just mentioned for what's coming
so there will be a time of trouble such
as never was
and basically anybody who doesn't fit
into this system
has to be eradicated
so martin you also see it
as a movement
to get rid of all those
who have very firm views and will not be
shaken and easily integrated into
this new system yes and
obviously it will hone in eventually
upon those
that dare to call the very system that
wants to
defend this situation uh
the false prophet or god forbid
to call the beast antichrist and to
attach it to the roman catholic system
so once you have all of this in place
then i believe the great persecution
will begin
the first quotes that we've showed
adventism
will seven the adventists will become
prominent in the news we've seen it as
already happened
and just one thing that i would also say
uh
from what this person just mentioned in
the video
what will be important is not to hate
the people that you may not hate you
must love your enemies
yeah but martin once this purge has
taken place if it does
what will remain of christianity a
liberal form of christianity
isn't that correct and a liberal form of
christianity
will certainly be arrayed
against adventism and particularly
against the sabbath particularly if the
sabbath
becomes part of the great movement to
save the planet low dartusi
so can you see the seventh-day
adventists
and the sabbath in particular becoming
an
issue of prominence yes and that is
exactly
what the bible says it will happen like
the third angels message was in 1844
definitely so it will happen so
i hope that that makes the issue
somewhat clearer
so let's pray
heavenly father you have predicted a
time of turmoil
we are seeing a time of turmoil
you haven't predicted that there will be
betrayals
that people will be handed over
and we are seeing betrayals
we are seeing the very things that the
bible predicts
and we stand upon the word of god
and lord we believe that to stand firm
upon this
rock this immovable rock the word of god
is the only hope for humanity and we
pray that you will come with the clouds
of heaven
to do that which you have promised to
cleanse this earth
from all unrighteousness is my prayer in
jesus name
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you